- I think it might work.
(upbeat music)
- Prepare for someone to
look really stupid right now.
- I don't even know how to
go about this, all right.
- And are there any rules for my hands?
There's one hand on the bottle.
- My first instinct is to
just yank it really fast.
- I'm sure no one else has tried this too.
Yeah that didn't work.
- If I blow maybe one way and
keep that intact, maybe, okay.
- Blowing can't be, that
can't be the solution.
- Nope.
- Okay I was gonna flip
the bottle upside down.
- is that legal, is this legal?
- Oh my gosh I know there's an easy way
and if you tell me I'm
really gonna be pissed.
- Dammit.
- Yeah let me just turn it this way
like that's gonna do something.
Fold it, nope.
- Can I just
put the bottle over it?
- And that's how you scoop them.
- I know this is smarter than this.
I was in advanced classed in school.
- What am I supposed--
but.
- Maybe some sort of tapping
will get the dollar out.
- Oh I almost had it.
- Was I warm when I folded it?
(bubbly music)
- I don't know what to do.
I'm sorry mom and I'm sorry dad.
- What?
- Oh my god.
- Ah that's pretty cool.
(upbeat music)
- What?
- Whoa, that was like the coolest thing.
You licked it and smacked
it in such a cool way.
That sounds really nasty.
(upbeat music)